hey i don't know how i missed this this
was a few days ago but yesterday people
sent me clips and i do want to talk
about it because there's some
interesting stuff here uh a a uh i was
gonna say a journalist a man named dan
ball from oan one america news had a
one-on-one interview with donald trump
apparently the interview was very long
and it was a bizarre interview in every
way
and i think there's a few interesting
things here and i want to look at them
with you let's start with the first clip
where donald trump again pushes the big
lie that he actually won in 2020
um and then claims the country's not
actually going to survive this now that
has some interesting implications let's
listen again you know i don't want to be
naive i think they're grossly
incompetent i really do i don't think
it's of us because they cheat on the
elections they don't need votes they
cheat on the elections i mean you look
at 43 000 votes were found last night
they cheat on elections when you cheat
on elections you don't have to destroy
the country they're destroying our
country our country
will not survive this our country will
not survive and what does that mean the
country won't survive what it won't
survive joe biden being president for
four years what what exactly is it that
the country won't survive and what's the
timeline and it's funny how these
hyperbol uh these right wingers
claim the left is hyperbolic when the
left says
there is a timeline on dealing with
climate change after which we could hit
a point of no return they say look at
that hyperbole and then trump says the
country's not going to survive this what
do you mean look at where they're coming
from they're coming from yemen they're
coming from the middle east they're
coming from all countries that are very
sick countries very sick
very
mean
nasty
they're coming from
all countries that have so trump getting
visibly confused there and this goes
back to immigration and the unproven
idea that terrorists from yemen and
other countries are coming through the
u.s mexico border we still have no
evidence of that it could happen
theoretically that could happen we have
no evidence that that's actually taking
place
trump then saying again his line about
the cupboards were bare when he took
over but saying nobody could have
predicted a pandemic just could no who
could have predicted it masks
we were doing
what we did all of the cupboards were
bare including the u.s cupboard the
governors didn't have
anything we didn't because nobody really
ever thought a pandemic would happen
it sounds like sort of an ancient thing
you know or ago of course no one could
have predicted a pandemic
other than the pandemic response team
which trump disbanded when he became
president
and they even left a playbook about what
to do in the case of a pandemic which
they threw out 1917 which was so bad oh
and trump also mentioning the 1917 flu
which was of course in 1918 very very
strange stuff
then the interview moves on and oan host
dan ball
feeds the idea to trump that joe biden
is shipping people in from the middle
east to red states
to try to cheat an election just i mean
the interviewer feeding trump conspiracy
theories why do you think and this is
another thing just talking like about
the middle east why would the biden
administration want to allow by the end
of this year by most figures i've looked
up it's going to be 1.5 2 million
million
2 million by the end of the year why
would you want to do that are you trying
to that and we see we're shipping them
they're shipping to the midwest the
south ship i mean listen is there more
dehumanizing language than saying you're
shipping people like it's a computer red
states mostly is this a planned for
another way to cheat at elections so
they say it's the votes but i don't
think so again you know i don't want to
be naive i think they're grossly
incompetent then it gets into the
segment that the that we looked at
earlier um you have to understand
that they continue to insist
undocumented immigrants from latin
america are coming here in order to vote
and cheat in elections undocumented
immigrants
or non-citizens of any kind can't vote
and similarly
if an asylum seeker or refugee gets here
from afghanistan or wherever
um they can't vote they are not citizens
at least not initially there's a long
process there and so this is completely
and totally made up
um then they get into the kova death
toll is inflated it's not they they
continue to repeat this one
we did a great job in addition we report
all of our covid at a level that nobody
in the world does if somebody's dying of
a heart attack and dying of cancer and
there's somewhere close to being uh
somebody with covet they put it down as
cove now that's a lie that's it it is
not true
that if you have a heart attack
and your sister had coveted and you die
from the heart attack they say you died
of covet because you're cis that it's
just not true because believe it or not
the doctors get more money yes can we
please claim now that's also not true
what this goes back to is the fact that
it's more expensive to treat covid
patients on average
and so medicare
pays more money to hospitals that are
treating because the hospitals incur
greater costs and are doing more things
it's a complete lie that by just
claiming someone has covered you get
more money that it's been widely
debunked because that has upset me and i
think millions of americans well it's
upset people but it's a lie for the last
18 months this 623 thousand death toll
and the lovely and we'll get to cnn in a
minute the fake news their lovely death
ticker they head up the last 18 months
scaring the bejesus out of american
citizens i think to me is treasonous but
that's another story for another day
with you death counters are treason you
have it by the way and but again 623 is
not because it died and died from and by
the way if you look at china's real
numbers and if you look at other real
numbers all right so you guys understand
what's going on there just an outrageous
interview where it's often just trump
telling the lies but in this one
the interviewer is is as much of a
participant in the lies um and then
lastly really wacky uh trump suggests
that fox news was part of a conspiracy
to steal the election from him
and then
i'm upset in arizona and fox called it
early when i was leading big what did
fox know to do that
before we wrap things up here i want to
give a big thank you to not only
president donald j trump yeah so how did
fox know to call it early
a wacky interview and unfortunately
people are watching oan people are
watching this stuff
uh very very concerning and uh the
it
it's too radical for fox news understand
that they now criticize fox news as part
of the problem and it's only newsmax and
oan that will really tell you the truth
crazy uphill battle that we are fighting
here
one of our sponsors is shaker and spoon
the monthly cocktail subscription box
that delivers the ingredients and
recipes for amazing craft cocktails
right to your door i use shaker and
spoon to make cocktails at home always
fun the last one i made was citrus
paradisi nice combination of vodka tonic
lime green tea and rose nothing better
than rose you open the box everything
you need is right there the recipe card
all the ingredients except for the
alcohol it's great because they always
have ingredients that are really high
quality and hard to find the
instructions are easy so my cocktails
always turn out great even though i
don't know anything about mixing drinks
but you learn a lot of new things about
cocktails using shaker and spoon which i
love about it opening up your shaker and
spoon box is a great way to spend a
night in and you'll get twenty dollars
off when you use promo code pacman at
checkout go to shakerandspoon.com
pacman the link is down below